[Music]
what did you first think when you walked
into this facility i thought it was a
mars it's incredible yeah it looks like
it looks like a spaceship
you don't realize the magnitude of
something like this a project like this
until you see it with your own ice
this is the largest vertical farm in
canada it uses the latest agricultural
technology to grow fresh produce inside
all year long
cesar cappa is the head grower at
goodleaf farms
at this 45 000 square foot facility in
guelph ontario he grows baby lettuce
spinach arugula and an assortment of
microgreens
led lights replace the sun and the
plants receive nutrients through water
rather than soil
every aspect of this environment is
controlled
from the hue of the lights to the amount
of carbon dioxide in the air
the result is astounding higher crop
yields that require less space and 95
percent less water
and there's no need for pesticides
working on a farm is nothing new to you
but i imagine that this is not exactly
the farm you grew up on yeah exactly
yeah i grew up in a small farm in
argentina this is completely different
but the objective is the same is
sustainability is food security
canada imports most of its leafy greens
from california
but recent supply chain disruptions have
exposed how precarious it is to rely on
produce from abroad we had labor
disruptions but we also had the problem
that california is in the middle of an
unprecedented drought and even when the
system is working perfectly
quality is really low even in the major
cities
lenoir newman is the director of the
food and agriculture institute at the
university of the fraser valley
by the time we get lettuce in british
columbia in vancouver it's already
traveled for eight days and its shelf
life is really only about 10 days when
it comes into the distributor they
usually throw away a third to 40 percent
of what they bought and when you take
what's left home you've only got a
couple of days to make a salad max
[Music]
this is exactly what barry murchie hopes
vertical farming will solve he's the ceo
of goodleaf farms and wants to rid our
lives of empty shelves and mushy leaves
so you take a look at all of those
elements and you say is there an
alternative is there a better way and
this is an example of how technology and
agriculture has merged to create an
alternative that is really better in
every element and is this something that
you can taste absolutely it's really
like going to your garden any day of the
year and picking something fresh because
it tastes like it's fresh at your garden
there are now hundreds of vertical farms
across asia europe and north america
where real estate is scarce and there
are a lot of mouths to feed
vertical farms could also help remedy
food insecurity in rural and remote
parts of canada
these are technologies that could get
more food
into regions where food is very
expensive
and often just plain unavailable
the technology is relatively new
leafy greens and small fruits thrive in
this type of system but other produce
still poses a challenge
and while traditional farms are
vulnerable to climate change
vertical farms are at the mercy of
energy prices
the lights require a lot of electricity
how sustainable these farms are depends
in part on where that power comes from
good leaf estimates its carbon footprint
is half that of a traditional farm
our challenge now is we just need to
build more of these
fruits and vegetables make up only part
of the average canadian's diet we also
love to eat meat
and despite the popularity of
plant-based alternatives the world's
appetite for animal protein is climbing
and it brings with it some big
challenges the meat industry is one of
the largest contributors to greenhouse
gas emissions it is one of the world's
largest land users this is on top of the
fact that there are serious ethical
concerns with animal protein
we've really focused this last 50 years
on making protein cheap
and we've done that at the expense of
animal welfare
the magnitude of this dilemma has given
rise to a new industry
cellular agriculture
where scientists grow animal products
without the animals
at the forefront of this protein
revolution is wild type
all right here's our small piece of wild
type salmon this sushi grade salmon
fillet was grown entirely in a lab
wild-type co-founder arya elfinbine got
the idea while visiting a ranch
as he watched cattle graze where a lush
rainforest once was he got to thinking
do we need animals to have meat could we
just create what we consume just outside
of the animal that's kind of where where
it began
when it came time to decide which
protein to focus on arya says salmon was
an early front-runner
salmon is the most consumed fin fish in
the u.s it's also one of the most
versatile fish that we consume in terms
of all the different culinary traditions
for ben friedman the head of product at
wild type
the choice was more personal
i grew up in the pacific northwest from
a family that spent a lot of time salmon
fishing
and just over the course of my own short
lifetime i've seen the population
decline in in a really incredible way
and so for me i think of wild type as an
opportunity to take pressure off the
wild fisheries
there are other benefits too
wild-type salmon is free of mercury
microplastics and other contaminants
commonly found in seafood and it only
takes four to six weeks to grow a fillet
like this one
in comparison farm salmon takes about
three years to go from egg to harvest
lab-grown protein or cultured meat is an
emerging technology
toronto startup celaegtech gave us a
closer look at how these cells are grown
co-founder valentin fulga and his team
are working on a replacement for snapper
so what's in this little container
you're holding what we have here is the
cells
so
they are growing all the time and you
can see here for example this cell is
dividing
the living cells are set in a
nutrient-rich liquid where they grow
until they run out of space you see here
all the surfaces full of cells it means
that we can move them they need the new
home they need a bigger home
scaling up this process is the biggest
hurdle for that
cells need to be grown in bioreactors
large tanks like you'd see at a brewery
it's a complex and costly process
but wild-type and other cellular
agriculture companies are forging ahead
as they await regulatory approval
like all new technology wild-type salmon
will come at a premium at first
our mission is one of greater
accessibility that's not one that we can
reach if we are just selling expensive
salmon
once the price of cellular agriculture
products drops below
animal produced protein cost then things
get interesting we're going to see large
producers they're saying well my
customers need hamburgers i can
buy this product it's cheaper it's
healthier it's better for the
environment cultured meat is not
destined to replace the trillion dollar
meat industry at least not anytime soon
but it will be an ethical and
sustainable alternative for those who
don't want to give up meat
what we eat changes 150 years ago we ate
a lot of wild game i quite confidently
do predict that in a hundred years
there'll be
very little animal agriculture on earth
we'll look back at industrial slaughter
and we'll say wow it's amazing we did
that
and wow we have a way better product